california es uno de los estados con los
impuestos más altos de todo eeuu y
también uno de los más caros no sólo eso
el gobierno de california vive en un
continuo riesgo de bancarrota con unas
deudas y unos déficits fiscales brutales
[Música]
sin embargo y pese a todo esto en
california es donde está la tercera zona
más rica y próspera del planeta tierra
sí amigos de visual política estoy
hablando del valle de santa clara
y decís que no sabéis de lo que hablo
tal vez os suene más el nombre popular
que recibe esta zona silicon valley
exacto el lugar donde nacieron empresas
como google apple y por supuesto o
youtube
[Música]
y lo más llamativo de todo es que no se
trata de ninguna gran metrópolis como
pueda ser nueva york o londres todo lo
contrario ciudades como cupertino
paloalto o mountain view tienen poco más
de 60 mil habitantes mellow park que es
donde facebook tiene la sede es más
pequeño que incluso teruel la capital
más pequeña de españa pues bien en esta
zona el salario medio supera los 10 mil
dólares al mes y es donde viven muchas
de las mayores fortunas del planeta y
por si alguno se lo preguntaba no no hay
ninguna mina de silicio en el valle de
santa clara el nombre de silicon valley
se empezó a utilizar en los años 70
porque aquí es donde se fabricaban los
microchips y semiconductores que por si
no lo sabéis están hechos de silicio
pero no lo busques porque no hay
recursos naturales por ningún lado
así que la pregunta es por qué aquí es
decir qué tiene de especial silicon
valley para tener tantísimas empresas
por ejemplo es fácil entender por qué
suiza es tan rica verdad tienen
impuestos bajos y sobre todo un sistema
político único en el mundo lo mismo
ocurre con muchos otros países de los
que ya os hemos hablado aquí en visual
político sin embargo desde el punto de
vista de la política silicon valley no
tiene nada especial es más como os hemos
dicho
california es uno de los estados con
mayor carga fiscal de todo estados
unidos
[Música]
por ejemplo imagina que eres un
directivo de una empresa y que cobras
medio millón de dólares al año si
vivieras en texas pagarías un 32% de
impuesto sobre la renta aproximadamente
sin embargo en california tendrías que
pagar un 42% en otras palabras que no
hablamos de una diferencia pequeña así
que de nuevo la pregunta es por qué
silicon valley y no texas o delaware o
cualquier otro lugar y lo que es más
importante que hace tan especial a
silicon valley como se crea una startup
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
los 8 traidores hay momentos en la
historia donde se dan todas las
casualidades para generar un milagro así
es como nació silicon valley nuestra
historia empieza en el año 1956 con una
empresa que se llamaba laboratorio de
semiconductores shock ley
[Música]
estos fueron los primeros en fabricar
microchips basados en silicio sus
oficinas estaban en un pueblecito de
poco más de siete mil habitantes que se
llamaba mountain view por aquel entonces
nadie hablaba de silicon valley por
supuesto la península de san francisco
ya era una de las grandes capitales
tecnológicas de eeuu
de hecho los radares que utilizaba el
ejército estadounidense ya estaban
fabricadas por una empresa que seguro
que os va a sonar a todos
hewlett packard
y la universidad de stanford ya generaba
profesionales formados en las
tecnologías más punteras pero volvamos a
nuestros amigos de exo clay sus
circuitos integrados eran lo más
innovador del momento y probablemente
esta empresa podría haber llegado muy
lejos pero tenían un problema
[Música]
por lo visto el jefe era un señor
insoportable tal cual como lo oís y que
creéis que pasó pues que un buen día
ocho de sus trabajadores más jóvenes se
plantaron en la oficina del jefe el
señor william clay y le dijeron mira
chaval te puedes meter tu empresa por el
top nosotros somos los que hemos
desarrollado tu tecnología somos el
cerebro de este negocio así que vamos a
montar nuestra propia empresa y te vas a
enterar a esos ocho señores se les
conoce como los ocho traidores
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque creo que
no os habéis dado cuenta de lo
arriesgada que era esta operación estos
ocho traidores tenían una media de 30
años cada uno no tenían dinero y querían
montar una empresa hiper tecnológica que
requería un montón de inversión creéis
que algún banco les iba a dar algún
préstamo pues obviamente no así que mis
queridos amigos de visual político en el
año 1959 nació la primera empresa
financiada íntegramente con un fondo de
capital-riesgo pero esto qué significa
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
de una idea desde los inicios del
capitalismo siempre ha habido gente con
dinero dispuestos a asociarse con gente
con ideas para montar empresas sin
embargo después de la segunda guerra
mundial montones de soldados vuelven del
frente
y uno de cada dos veteranos quiere
montar una empresa es decir que de la
noche a la mañana hay muchísima demanda
para financiar negocios y eso lleva a
que mucha de esta gente con dinero se
replanteé las cosas
por ejemplo lawrence rockefeller de los
rockefeller de toda la vida
[Música]
este hombre no solo tenía dinero también
conocía a otras personas que también
tenían mucho dinero así que en el año
1959 les llamó a todos y les dijo a ver
mis queridos amigos millonarios dejad
vuestras copas de champagne y vuestras
latas de caviar por un momento y prestar
mi atención
he encontrado a ocho chicos en
california que tienen una idea
fantástica son más listos que el hambre
y quieren desarrollar no sé qué cosa
rara de un circuito integrado con
silicio así que si queréis me dais
vuestro dinero y yo lo invierto en su
negocio y si sale bien nos forramos y
como decimos siempre en visual político
dicho y hecho
así es como en 1959 estos ocho traidores
de silicon valley con el dinero de
rockefeller montaron fairchild la
primera empresa en comercializar
microchips de silicio pero no sólo eso
así es como nació uno de los primeros
fondos de capital-riesgo del rock
asociated y donde tienen la sede os
preguntaréis pues en paro alto eso está
en silicon valley por supuesto la idea
era muy arriesgada por eso se llaman
fondos de capital-riesgo
[Música]
si por ejemplo tú inviertes tu dinero en
una empresa que ya existe como por
ejemplo cocacola es muy difícil que te
arruines sin embargo dar dinero a
alguien que solo tiene una idea y mucho
talento es una auténtica locura cuál es
la ventaja pues que si te sale bien
multiplica su valor dónde está el
secreto entonces en invertir en muchas
ideas a la vez basta con que una de cada
diez de salga bien para que hayas
amortizado a la inversión y lo cierto es
que a nuestro amigo el señor rockefeller
la inversión inserta y le salió a las
mil maravillas tanto es así que la
empresa todavía existe y tiene oficinas
por todo el mundo
y qué pasa cuando las cosas te van bien
pues que otros salen a imitarte para el
año 1982 ya había doce fondos de
capital-riesgo establecidos en alguno de
los municipios de sillicon valley
la filosofía es muy sencilla el fondo
atrae dinero de inversores privados
planes de pensiones y por supuesto
millonarios de todo eeuu y de todo el
mundo y después los profesionales que
trabajan para el fondo se reúnen con los
emprendedores y van buscando qué ideas
merecen la pena y qué ideas no merecen
la pena
en resumen que silicon valley lo tenia y
lo tiene todo profesionales de altísimo
nivel que se forman en la universidad de
stanford profesionales de altísimo nivel
que se forman en todo el mundo y que
terminan tarde o temprano emigrando a
silicon valley un tejido empresarial que
permite crear nuevos negocios y sobre
todo el dinero de todo el mundo el resto
es historia pero vale todo esto suena
muy bien pero y como es una empresa de
silicon valley cómo funciona este
sistema de startups y fondos de
capital-riesgo pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
el método silicon valley lo sé lo sé hoy
en día el término startup se ha
convertido en una de esas palabras que
dicen los idiotas cuando quieren parecer
inteligentes así que cuál es la
diferencia entre una empresa normal y
una startup pues aquí tenéis una buena
definición
una startup es una empresa diseñada para
crecer rápido
paul graham creador de yahoo gestor e
inversor de riesgo ya se lo que estáis
pensando no se supone que todas las
empresas están diseñadas para crecer
rápido pues la respuesta es simple y
llanamente no vamos a poner un ejemplo y
que a ikea puede ser una de las
compañías más exitosas de todos los
tiempos pero una de sus máximas desde
los inicios era que sólo podían crecer
usando sus propios fondos
ni deudas con bancos ni fondos de
inversión
eso significa que a diferencia de otras
empresas y que a tardo mucho más en
crecer pero como pudo hacerlo tal vez lo
hizo de una forma más estable y os
preguntaréis quién si sería una startup
entonces pues por ejemplo facebook
porque primero porque facebook es un
negocio escalable es decir da igual si
tiene uno o un millón de usuarios los
gastos son prácticamente los mismos pero
no sólo eso facebook es un ejemplo del
libro de lo que se conoce como el ciclo
de financiación de una startup
[Música]
y prestad atención porque esto es la
clave del funcionamiento de silicon
valley el primer paso es lo que se
conoce como el valle de la muerte y por
qué lo llaman así pues porque es el
momento donde la mayor parte de los
proyectos no llegan a sobrevivir en este
caso teníamos a nuestros amigos mark
zuckerberg y eduardo saverin que tenían
una muy buena idea bajo el brazo pero
tener una muy buena idea por si mismo no
sirve de nada hay que ejecutarla así que
estos dos amigos pusieron dinero de su
propio bolsillo para sacar el primer
prototipo de la página en este caso
hablamos de de facebook.com
el resto de la historia ya lo conocéis
enseguida todos los alumnos de harvard
tenían una cuenta y el proyecto prometía
bien siguiente paso tiene que
convertirse en una empresa como dios
manda y para eso hace falta dinero
dinero con el que poder pagar servidores
programadores campañas de publicidad
etcétera tenían ese dinero obviamente no
que hicieron entonces marcharse a
silicon valley y reunirse con este señor
que veis en la pantalla que se llama
peter thiel
[Música]
y atentos porque aquí llega la primera
gran diferencia entre emprender en
sillicon valley o emprender en cualquier
otro lugar
peter thiel es lo que se conoce como un
business angels es decir un señor con
mucho dinero que está dispuesto a
invertir en una empresa que todavía se
encuentra en ese valle de la muerte en
este momento en el año 2004 facebook era
simplemente una idea con mucho potencial
pero que ni siquiera daba beneficios la
inversión era tan arriesgada que ningún
banco les prestaría dinero cuál es la
ventaja entonces pues que cuando peter
thiel metió media millón de dólares en
facebook estaba comprando un 10 por
ciento de la empresa y veréis por qué
solamente un 10 por ciento a fin de
cuentas en ese momento facebook no valía
nada con ese medio millón de dólares
peter thiel podría haber exigido el 50 o
incluso se el 100% de la empresa verdad
[Música]
pues si podría hacerlo si estuviera en
un lugar remoto de alabama pero esto es
silicon valley y hay cientos de
'business angels' como peter thiel así
que todos ellos compiten por ofrecer
buenas condiciones a sus emprendedores
empezáis a entender porque merece la
pena emprender en esta zona pues bien
volvamos a la historia
[Música]
por ese medio millón de dólares los
fundadores mark zuckerberg eduardo
saverin ya pueden crear algo grande algo
comercializable dicho de otra forma este
es el momento en el que se ve si una
empresa sobrevive o no al valle de la
muerte pero la cosa no se queda aquí
probablemente si facebook si hubiera
fundado en alabama se habrían quedado en
esta fase a fin de cuentas ya tienen un
proyecto funciona
basta con que dé beneficios suficientes
como para cubrir gastos y punto pero
recordáis que esto es una startup y que
su propósito es crecer lo más rápido
posible pues aquí es donde entran los
fondos de capital-riesgo
[Música]
y ya no hablamos de un señor como peter
thiel que tiene mucho dinero y lo
invierte se trata de empresas
especializadas empresas que no sólo te
dan dinero sino que también te asesoran
y esto es muy importante porque en
muchos casos pueden llegar a tomar
decisiones cruciales de tu empresa ya
decirte cómo tienes que diseñar la
estructura corporativa con que otras
empresas te tienes que asociar o incluso
cuando tienes que salir al mercado
internacional en este caso en el año
2005 un fondo que se llama apple
partners metió la friolera de 12 7
millones de dólares y con esto se
quedaban con el 13 por ciento de la
empresa y aquí vamos a hacer un
paréntesis si recordáis peter team él
había comprado un 10 por ciento de
facebook por medio millón de dólares sin
embargo ahora accel partners ha pagado
12 7 millones por el 13 por ciento eso
significa que de la noche a la mañana
facebook se ha revalorizado y ahora vale
98 millones de dólares dicho de otra
forma en menos de un año la inversión de
peter thiel ya se había multiplicado por
casi un 2000
como os quedáis pues esperar porque
todavía no habéis visto nada esta
entrada de capital de acl partners es lo
que se conoce como una ronda de
inversión de serie
y si existe una serie a es porque luego
hay una serie b o incluso una c en este
caso la ronda de serie c la protagonizó
microsoft en el año 2007 y atenidos a
los números porque os va a explotar la
cabeza microsoft pagó 240 millones de
dólares por un 16 por ciento de facebook
si hacemos la regla de 3 tenemos que en
este momento facebook ya vale 15 mil
millones de dólares eso significa que
ese 10% que compró peter thiel por medio
millón de dólares se ha revalorizado
ahora en un 300 mil por ciento en sólo
tres años
o dicho de otra forma si tú hubieras
invertido 100 dólares en facebook en el
año 2004 tres años más tarde ya te
podrías estar comprando una casa con
piscina trastero y hasta campo de
minigolf pero vale ya sé lo que os
estáis preguntando de verdad facebook
vale todo eso es decir en el año 2007
facebook está bastantes beneficios como
para justificar la inversión pues no
pero veréis con todo ese dinero se
pueden hacer muchas cosas cosas que
tarde o temprano terminarán dando
beneficios y aquí es cuando llegamos a
la fase final de la startup el momento
en el que tienen que tomar la decisión
crucial vendemos o salimos a bolsa en el
caso de facebook decidieron salir a
bolsa pero muchas otras empresas
terminan siendo compradas por grandes
multinacionales por ejemplo ésta
[Música]
apple compra shazam por 400 millones de
dólares y ya sé lo que me vais a decir
fonseca todo esto suena muy bonito pero
no me creo que sea tan fácil y lo cierto
es que 9 de cada 10 startups fracasan
por el camino pero basta con que una
funcione para que un montón de gente se
haga millonaria y eso explica que la
máxima de la política hoy en día sea
ponga un silicon valley en su vida
porque las calles de berlín son el nuevo
silicon valley de europa
guadalajara el silicon valley mexicano
los nuevos silicon valley de áfrica
[Música]
en fin que todo el mundo quiere tener un
silicon valley en las puertas de su casa
todo el mundo menos la gente que vive en
silicon valley
[Música]
y te tecnológica está abandonando
silicon valley en manada pero de eso
vamos a hablar en otro vídeo mientras
tanto la pregunta es creéis que se puede
replicar el modelo de silicon valley en
otros países
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto no olvidéis
visitar nuestra página de patrián para
apoyar este proyecto recordad que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros a este canal para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like compartirlo con
vuestros amigos y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto